If a mouse wearing a hat ran
into my home right now, I'd move.
I would pack and I would leave and I'd never
come back. I wouldn't be like, oh yeah.
Regardless of what kind of hat?
Help me sweep.
Be better, Disney princesses. I'm here
with Tom and Nina to talk about the
worst character traits of the Disney princesses.
Finally, those princesses are going to get it.
My pick for the worst character
traits of the Disney princesses,
I struggled with this because it's
hard to pick. It's just hard to pick.
What can I say? It's hard to choose.
There are so many terrible traits.
No, the best thing I could come up with is that
I think that they're too trusting of animals.
They always seem to have at least one animal
companion that's just always down for whatever
adventure they're on. I'm just kind of like, have
you met animals? Animals are not cooperative.
You need to have special trainers just to get
them to do the thing that they're supposed to do.
Sometimes they carry disease.
Often.
In the wild.
They often do.
Yeah, they not safe.
Which one had all the animals help
her do all the chores in her house?
Couple of them.
Cinderella.
Was it that Snow White? Cinderella?
Snow White.
It could be Cinderella.
Cinderella. Cinderelli,
Cinderelli, right? All of the mice?
Yes.
Come on.
It's disgusting.
If a mouse wearing a hat ran
into my home right now. I'd move,
I would pack and I would leave and I'd never
come back. I wouldn't be like, oh yeah.
Regardless of what kind of hat?
Help me sweep.
You're in Paris so I assume it would be a beret.
I would assume. Yeah.
Would that change anything or no?
No.
Did you just shut down Ratatouille
as a possibility?
Patton Oswalt is a gentleman.
Yeah. I would love for Patton Oswalt to cook in my
home, not a rat. They carry disease, a lot of it.
So that's my pick. They often
have an animal sidekick or two
and they're just, why? You can
get by without some random animal,
and they always pick the weirdest animals too.
Tangled, she just has a chameleon for some reason.
Is that even native to where she lives?
I don't think so.
I was confused by that too. I was
like, where did they get this?
It's just an odd choice. It's a little weird.
Did they run out of animals?
They might have.
That might have been it.
They were like, well, we've done
mice, we've done birds, we've done...
Raccoons, hummingbirds, crickets, luck dragons.
Right, the very common
woodland creature, luck dragon. So I guess
iguana or chameleon rather is the next.
I think it's a chameleon.
No it's a chameleon.
Does it matter?
Because it changes colors.
Anyway, that's my pick. They're too
trusting of animals. I don't trust animals.
I never will trust animals. That's my pick.
Nina, what is your pick for the worst
character traits of the Disney princesses?
First of all, I do think we need to
maybe change the name under Brian
to say Brian Rubin: does not trust animals.
I think we.
Hoping that can.
I would love that.
I would love to see that.
Either we'll do that or this
whole section will be cut.
Perfect.
We'll see. We'll find out.
So Brian, I took a different approach to this,
but I do want to leapfrog of what you said
as a generalized bad personality trait, which
is that they are all just extremely, not even
passive aggressive, there's no aggression,
they're just passive. Like everything happens.
Like, Cinderella's stepsisters and
stepmother, you can't go to the ball,
stay home and sweep the floor. And she's like,
well my legs don't work, I can't walk there.
Oh no, whatever shall I do? And she has
to wait around for her fairy godmother.
And then of course she pulls off the
most famous Irish exit in history.
The Irish goodbye.
Yeah a favorite of bar flies everywhere.
Ariel's like, oh no, why can't I talk to a
human male? I'm like, put your head above
water and talk to them. This isn't hard.
Snow White never says or does anything of
importance to be honest. But the biggest bone
I have to pick, and this really kind of hurts
because as a kid, I really loved Beauty and the
Beast. And I was a kid who read a lot. And so I
really identified with Belle. It's the bookworm
princess or whatever, but man, she is a jerk.
She just walks around her village every single
morning, singing the rudest song I've ever heard.
She's like, look at these dumb, crappy people
living their lives in this beautiful French
village. Oh, I got to get out of here. This sucks.
But she says, hello.
Yeah she says, hello. And immediately
segues into, there's the guy doing the
same thing he does every day, what a loser.
And then just keeps going. I mean, god, no.
Provincial, am I right?
No wonder nobody in her town likes her. I
wouldn't, I'd be like... There is a famous
tweet that I took inspiration from where it's
villagers, there goes Belle singing her daily
mean song about us. And I'm just imagining
this. And I'm like, yeah, I understand why
she's unpopular and everyone thinks she's weird
because she walks around the town just saying
offensive things to everybody. Whereas yes, Gaston
is objectively a bigger jerk, but he at least
sucks up to everybody a little bit more.
He's of the people.
Yeah, he tries. She's just like screw
all of you. I'm getting out of here. Oh,
okay, what are you going to do? Go
to college Belle. It's like 1500,
no problem, unless a beast kidnaps you,
you're really not going anywhere. Get off.
She's going to go live with a giant demon.
Whatever. Get off your high horse Belle. I'm
sick of Belle. I don't like Belle's attitude.
I like her general vibe of being learned and
reading books and being really jazzed about
libraries. But I don't like her crappy attitude
and her judgemental instincts. So I'm going to go
ahead and pick Belle. And then I don't even really
know where to start with a character like Ariel.
Fair enough.
Not great.
Where do we even go from there?
Well, I know where we should
go. Let's go to Tom. Tom,
what's your pick for the worst
character traits as a Disney princess?
I want to start out by thanking you for giving me
the opportunity as a 33 year old straight guy to
talk on the internet about Disney princesses at
great length. This is clearly my comfort zone.
And I'm looking forward to it.
It was what you were born to do.
Thank you Nina. Hi Nina. I don't know very
much about this. I felt a little bit out of
my element. I do think that it's maybe a little
bit dismissive to say what's the worst trait of
all of the Disney princesses, which was my read on
the prompt. I don't know if I did that correctly,
so instead I decided that we should probably
look at all of them just real quick.
I had a feeling we'd be back
at the whiteboard today.
I just want to do a really quick one. It's not a
huge deal. I'm assuming that by Disney princess,
we're talking about the branded trademark Disney
princess logo. Which we mean the 12 official
Disney princess, starting out of course, with
the original Snow White, my big problem with her,
all of her best friends are dudes, that's
kind of a red flag. Cinderella, all of my
best friends are rats, double red flag. Sleeping
Beauty, I didn't have a huge problem with Aurora,
the big problems that she only has 18 lines
in the movie. I don't know if you know that,
but she doesn't really do anything. We don't know
who this is as a character, the prince doesn't
know who she is as a character, is she racist?
We don't know, we never find out, so sketchy.
By the way, I do want to point out
that these top four right here,
they do all fall into a category that I have
branded, needs, to your original point. Needs to
stop trusting wild animals and old magic women,
or in the case of Ariel, drag royalty. Jasmine.
Shout out to Divine.
Jasmine is a... She is a wealthy, one-percenter who vacations
by pretending that she's a poor person, that
seems kind of problematic.
Wow, that's perfect.
Pocahontas, she does fall in love with Mel Gibson
in the movie, which is nobody's favorite trait
in anybody. Also, she has Voldemort nose.
Mulan, killed a lot of people in that movie.
She did, that's true.
Besides that, I don't have a ton of issues with
her. Aside from that, my little sister had the
soundtrack for the movie and she played it on
repeat for about six months and there's only
so much Donny Osmond that you can stand. Also,
all of her best friends are dude's, red flag.
Ariel. Ariel's 16 years old, she's illiterate,
she only understands love as either an abstract
fantasy that she builds up in her head without
having anything real to back it up with, or as
a series of giant sacrifices that people make, or
her dad gets turned into a worm and she's like,
oh, we finally likes me, speaking to her dad.
She still calls him daddy at 16 which is...
Constantly puts her friends in danger. She ain't
even know what forks is. I could go on about
Ariel, she's got a lot going on.
Bad table manners at the very least.
Yeah.
And then Belle, I hate to argue
with you Nina, she seems cool.
The original hipster.
She reads a lot. She seems kind of a big misanthrope.
So what, is she better than everyone else?
I mean a little bit. She sees a
hairy dude, who doesn't like people
and she says, I think I can fix him.
So I think we've got some insight.
Something about that, that speaks to me Nina.
I think we know now what Tom does every morning
when he goes out for his morning stroll,
he just goes up and goes, oh, look at
this loser. Just out loud, singing.
He's got a book in his hand.
I demand a new book from another guy.
Instead of drinking coffee, Tom does that.
It gives him the energy he needs for his day.
It's more or less it. Unless you guys
want to keep talking about Ariel.
If you want.
Do you want to keep talking about Ariel?
Sounds like you want to.
I don't know how much time we have.
Are we okay on time right now?
We're great on time. You go right ahead.
All right.
Do you have a second whiteboard?
So this is going to take a second to adjust.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry. This will just...
this part is a little shaky here.
Wow. It looks great.
Beginning at the top...
But I think that there are better female role
models for young women by way of example.
Oh my God.
Nina correct me if I'm wrong but I
believe that it was in season 12,
episode nine, Grey's Anatomy, the episode titled,
The Sound of Silence. Written by Stacey McKee
and of course directed by Denzel Washington.
We have to cut all this, don't we?
Maybe, we'll see. Go on.
Where one doctor, Meredith Grey said,
after being attacked by a patient and
losing her ability to speak for the
majority of the episode, she said, you have
a voice, use it, speak up, raise your hands,
shout your answers, make yourself heard, whatever
it takes, just find your voice. And when you do,
fill the damn silence. I leave you with that.
Also, at the bottom right here, it says
I never saw Tangled or Moana or Brave,
or the Princess and the Frog, so I really
don't have anything to say about that.
Bye everybody.
Bye.
Thanks for watching. Please hit like and
subscribe. So you don't miss a single video.